all right what do you got for us since
all the characters have food names what
food would you be I'd like to be
Savannah strawberry I love a strawberry
I want to be macaroni and cheese so that
doesn't go with that meat not a fruit
either no you're right how about true
date
I love dates I love a majority okay I'd
be Drew date go
up dates don't get enough attention
either well if I would have a food name
mine would start with W for watermelon
ooh that is a great fruit you get an
animal sidekick what animal would be
yours it can be any animal I think
you're a cat person am I right I do have
four cats well that's what I thought I
do love cats but if I wasn't to have a
cat I would love to have a Capuchin
monkey
um because they're they're so cute and
like fun they seem too energetic for me
I think I'd like it an aging dog you
know just somebody I'd like my sidekick
to be someone kind of low energy who
likes to nap maybe snuggle up with me
I'm a kind of a snuggler now I'm
rethinking my sidekick I want sloth
exactly now we're talking well if I
would have an animal psychic I would
have a fish his name would be watermelon
though but also what names would your
pets have
Freckle for the sloth yeah oh [__] with
a sloth yeah Freckle the sloth
um Roger watzo the dog
you look so well dressed today by the
way Tariq I love your outfit very
handsome there's still one more question
that you have to answer okay go ahead
inside the princess Pebble tree house
and what would your room look like I'd
like to live right about there when the
teapot spout because I feel like there'd
be a lot of light coming in and I could
go out and have a great view honestly
it's very tall I'm gonna hope there's an
elevator and not just stairs so that
then you would according to this ring
get all your steps oh sorry so no
offense but you're kind of sticking my
Red Canyon actually I think what you
should do is ask Tariq how he built his
electric staircase oh yeah it could be
next it could be it could go from here
all the way
into what I have the meeting
where's your room next to the water oh
yeah so I could sew I could go swimming
with them all with watermelon on my face
where's your room Jersey well I live
here because according to my new ring I
need to work out more so I'm going to
climb this ladder every single day oh so
you most so you mostly want to be you
mostly want to be Penelope yes yes I'm
mermaids with Penelope it's pretty cool
that elevator it could be like right
there a donut cream yeah and then it
could take me all the way
come over will you hang out with us
thank you thank you cutie you did a
great job group hugs
sweetheart we'll see you out in the
Kingdom okay yeah
[Music]